As part of big think mentor,
which is,
um,
big things,
lifelong learning channel on Youtube.
I'm Jason Gods and we're very,
very happy today to be joined by Maria
Konnikova,
author of mastermind,
how to think like Sherlock Holmes in her
workshop on big think mentor.
She teaches thinking skills from the
masters sleuth including observation
deduction and imaginative problem
solving among others.
And we're here as a followup to that
workshop with Sin Burgess who's a member
of big think,
mentors,
learning community.
Uh,
welcome Maria.
We're delighted that you're here.
Thank you so much for having me.
I'm excited for this.
I've never done a google plus hanging
out before,
so,
um,
and this is our first ever,
so bear with us if there's background
noise or any other technical
interruptions or you know,
suddenly the Google plus animation of a
mustache or you're on one of us.
Um,
so I think what we'll do,
we'll start with,
you know,
essentially this is a follow on to
Maria's workshop on mentor,
which is called how to think like a
Sherlock Holmes.
You can get there by going to
youtube.com/user/big thing mentor.
And we're asking followup questions.
Um,
I have some questions.
We've got other questions from members
of mentors community and we'll start
with,
um,
sid,
uh,
and said if you'd like to introduce
yourself would say a couple of words
about what brought you to mentor or
what,
you know,
what you're,
what you're up to.
Um,
and then,
uh,
and then go ahead and ask Maria your
questions.
Yeah,
I saw just,
I think
Sid Burgess,
I think I'm just kind of addicted to the
notion of trying to,
um,
hone a personal skills to try to,
you know,
improve your life and day to day,
uh,
just I enjoy the topic in general.
So I've been a big fan of,
uh,
of the channel and even before you guys,
went to a big thing for mentors.
I'm really kind of excited to be a part
of this.
Um,
yeah,
I had a question just to kind of kick
things off.
I really was curious,
uh,
what,
some of the mentors was wanting to get
out of this whole experience themselves.
Uh,
we,
we sort of are used to kind of receiving
this feedback or receiving this,
these good ideas,
but part of a,
part of the,
uh,
part of the brilliance of this whole
kind of community is,
is that everybody's kind of is getting
something out of it too as well.
So I was just kind of curious from your
what,
what are you looking to get out of a big
thing to mentor?
Well,
I'm looking to get out of it.
That's a wonderful question.
Questions just like the one that you
asked.
So when you really have,
um,
people who interact with you and who ask
new questions,
you've look at things in a different way
and it makes you think about topics that
you wouldn't think about otherwise,
which I think is really important.
So when I,
whenever I answer questions from
readers,
whenever I give talks,
answer questions from the audience,
there's,
you know,
there are always questions that repeat,
but there's always something new.
And I say,
Huh,
that's really interesting.
And then I start thinking about it and
it lets me develop my ideas.
It's kind of like the Holmes Watson
relationship actually to,
uh,
kind of bring it back to that.
I think that Watson really improves
Holmes's thinking and Holmes becomes
much better throughout the stories.
The more he interacts with Watson
because Watson asks provocative
questions,
he always forces homes to stop and think
why he's doing what he's doing.
And that kind of back and forth is
incredibly important,
um,
to keep your thinking sharp,
to keep yourself stimulated.
I don't think that anyone should ever
really work in a bathroom even though
writing is often a very solitary
profession.
But that interaction I think is
incredibly important.
Jason,
you want me ask my second question?
Absolutely.
Alright,
so the second one,
uh,
is,
it's one of the,
I've actually had a kind of mulling
around in my mind for a while as this
notion of,
of being too distracted and multitasking
and you brought it up in one of your
video.
So I really wanted to ask you this
specifically.
I enjoy going.
That's my favorite place in the world.
It really doesn't matter which one it
is,
is the coffee shop.
I just enjoy sitting in the coffee shop
and just kind of watching the world go
by and people watching as we like to
say,
but almost more than that too.
I just enjoy kind of just a,
almost in a sense of meditation,
just taking in all the sights and sounds
of whatever city that I'm in and trying
to process them almost simultaneously.
So I wanted to just ask you how,
how would you,
how would you describe maybe in a way
that would help help improve that,
uh,
that mental,
exercise and the way that differentiates
that from kind of the multitasking or
the endorphin driven kind of electronic
distraction?
Um,
uh,
that we hear a lot about.
Can you kind of,
you can maybe differentiate the two a
little bit and maybe how we can focus it
on,
on the better one?
Sure.
So what you like to do is definitely not
multitasking.
Um,
that's kind of unitasking at its best
because you're doing something very
specific.
You're kind of watching or letting your
senses take everything in.
So I think the,
the myth about multitasking,
you,
you can't be looking at multiple things
at once and have that not be
multitasking.
You can't be doing multiple activities
at once.
So their brain can't be thinking,
okay,
I want to do this,
but also I want to do this.
Oh,
I'm watching these people.
But also I'm focused on what I'm going
to order at the coffee shop,
when I'm going to have for lunch,
what I'm going to do after I leave the
coffee shop,
what else I have planned for this city.
If you were thinking all of these things
at the same time and then you'd be
multitasking,
but if you're kind of in the moment and
just soaking everything in using all of
your senses,
that's really sensory taking in the,
in a very mindful fashion.
Um,
which is the purpose of,
uh,
of mindfulness.
So I think those are two very,
very different experiences.
And in order to really,
I think do get a lot of out of what you
do and get more out of that type of
people watching,
which by the way,
I think is really interesting and
fascinating.
And helps you develop as a,
as a person and develop your thinking
and develop your powers of observation
is really realize that that's exactly
what you're doing and do your best to
avoid distracting thoughts.
So if you see someone and that puts your
mind along the lines of,
oh,
hey,
that person reminds me of my friend x
and settling,
you're thinking about fed x in your mind
is going on a tangent,
realize that that's happening.
Stop yourself and come back to just
observing and taking everything in.
I think that's how you can make the most
out of that experience.
Okay,
great.
Um,
I have other questions from other mentor
members who would have liked to have
been with us today but could not for
technical reasons.
So,
um,
we've got Matthew J.
Clark is asking what are the current
theories about why tasks switching
causes fatigue?
And that's,
that's how he worded the question.
And unfortunately,
folks aren't here to do follow up,
but
of course,
so we know that attention is an
incredibly finite resource.
So there's really only so much of it to
go around and we can train our intention
so that we become better,
but we'll never be able to make it
incident.
And so one of the things that tasks
which in does is use that mental energy.
So you need resources to switch your
focus from one thing to another.
And the theory is actually is very
simple.
The more your mind is doing,
the more resources it needs.
And so every time you switch your
attention who are actually switching
circuits,
you're switching your focus,
you're switching kind of the neural
mechanisms behind it and that expense
energy,
literally you can replenish it by having
glucose or other,
um,
other things that actually boosts your
energy levels.
So it's a very,
very literal thing that happens.
Your brain is actually getting tired,
you're actually using resources and
you're actually becoming less able to do
other things because you use those
resources for the task switching.
Now you no longer have them to pay
attention to the tasks that you're
doing.
There's a lot of really interesting work
that shows that people who multitask
frequently are less efficient at task
switching because they're always the,
they don't know how to take those
resources and really use them to their
full potential,
which I think is really fascinating
because it ends up that heavy
multitaskers become worse at the very
thing that they should be very good at.
Right,
right.
I've,
I've read some of that research and it's
fascinating because,
you know,
the,
the sort of plugged in millennial folks
who you would think would be the best
step at this actually the more they
multitask,
it seems the worst.
Yup.
They become a worse that being able to
filter out distractions.
Um,
and that's a good thing if you want to
make sure that you're paying attention
to everything,
but you also get off task very,
very frequently in very easily,
which is not a good thing.
So not being able to filter out
distractions can make them worse at task
switching to the tasks you actually want
to be switching to,
if that makes sense.
Yeah.
Something I'd be like,
oh,
Hey,
there was this distraction.
Maybe I'll do that instead.
So in this regard,
do you think that sort of,
we're all doomed given the,
you know,
tech,
technological,
uh,
the sort of multitasking world that
folks are growing up in now?
Or are there things people can do,
you know,
to,
uh,
to counteract that?
I mean,
you know,
there's concerns about people being
addicted.
Sure.
No,
I don't think we're all doing that all.
Um,
I think that technology is wonderful and
that we just need to be aware of how
much you will call it exerts on us and
how difficult that can be to avoid.
So what I would say is we need to learn
to train our attention.
Um,
because as with anything,
attention is like a muscle.
It's an analogy that you hear all over
and over until they college is self
control.
Like a muscle,
you know,
everything.
Basically you can say,
hey,
it's like a muscle because it's an
analogy that works incredibly well.
So if you train it,
it gets stronger,
it gets better.
You are able to know why ticking.
You have more endurance.
And similarly with attention,
the more you train yourself to the task
and to only pay attention to one thing
at a time,
the longer and longer and longer you're
able to maintain your focus.
So what's happening when people say that
they cannot pay attention is that they
haven't trained their attention.
They've forgotten what it is to have a
single minded focus.
And because they haven't trained it,
their attention actually has gotten
worse.
So I think that people know when they
say they cannot pay attention,
they really can't.
It doesn't just happen over night.
Um,
and so what we can do is try to monitor
ourselves and really learn to do one
thing at a time.
For me that's,
um,
there's been a lot that I've had to do
to actually maximize my own potential.
When I was writing mastermind,
I realized how Internet addicted I was
and I actually needed to install,
um,
freedom,
which is an internet blocking software
on my computer so that I wouldn't go
online.
And it was really hard for me.
But eventually I was able to stay off
mine for four or five hours at a time.
Um,
and I turned my phone off because
otherwise it'd be too tempted to,
uh,
check my internet on the iphone because
unfortunately,
freedom doesn't it get blocked all of
your devices and now I don't really need
it as often because I,
I know I do it and I've already trained
myself not to.
It's still nice once in a while.
I think we all need to give ourselves
mental breaks and realize that the
Internet is your fault,
but sometimes it's good to just focus
and not let those email notifications,
those twitter notification.
Yeah.
All of those things that can just sucker
attention.
No,
not,
not them interfere.
Gotcha.
And speaking of attention for our
viewers,
the noise that sounds like the ocean is
a most likely some,
you know,
Maria lives in a fairly noisy
neighborhood.
Nothing we can really do about that.
So that's what that is.
Um,
okay.
Let me continue with people's questions
because I could,
I could do followups here all day.
Um,
Matthew also asks,
how can you habituate an input from one
sense so that it does not interfere with
the attention you give to another sense.
For example,
reading body language while having a
conversation?
Well,
I think that there are actually two
different issues here.
Um,
habituation.
Yeah.
Is it very specific term when it comes
to psychology and you don't do it,
it just happens.
It's something that's incredibly,
incredibly natural.
So as soon as it,
as there's a stimulus that you're
hearing,
often you'd be,
you do become habituated to it.
Um,
so for instance,
one of my favorite examples comes from
my personal experience.
Um,
my freshman year of college,
I had a huge church right outside my
windows and the bells would ring and I'm
weekends.
It bells would ring.
And I was a college freshman.
I wanted to sleep.
Um,
and at first they always wake me up and
I got to the point where I didn't even
hear them.
I didn't realize that was for,
um,
we're ringing.
And it's not that I made a conscious
effort to habituate your brain learns to
lock out the noises that if serious all
the time and the same can be true of
vision.
So that's why you often,
you know,
if we tell us,
if you asked me,
no,
what do I pass on my waist work every
day,
I might not be able to answer think,
oh,
I know exactly what I pass,
but because I do it every day,
I don't pay attention to it because I've
become habituated to all those sites and
I may not,
it may not even notice that a store has
closed or in the store has opened in its
stead unless something draws my
attention to it and I'm out of my
situated,
um,
state.
So it just happens.
And what region do is actually not
habituated ourselves and try to is we
don't want to,
the active part is not habituation but
with standing habituation,
if that makes sense.
Gotcha.
Okay.
Um,
so one other question from another
mentor member,
John.
Francoise,
Noel,
um,
asks Watson is really helpful to homes.
Do you have tools or ideas for,
you know,
solutions to create our own imaginary
watson or other ways to get a similar
benefit without having a watson if you
don't have one?
Yeah,
that's uh,
it's interesting and I'd stopped short
of saying have imaginary people
conversations in your heads just because
that you could take that a little bit
too far,
but you can learn to kind of argue with
yourself and to always,
um,
that's actually how I get a lot of my
thinking done.
You know,
I say,
okay,
this is what I think,
what,
what's the counter argument to that?
Or why do I think that way?
So force yourself almost to be in a
debate or mindset always.
It doesn't just make you more critical
of yourself and make some critical all
of the information that you're taking in
of everything that you're reading is
everything that you are watching of all
of the constant news and other inputs
that you get every day isn't just don't
take it in as candid as you give him and
say,
oh,
that makes sense.
Rather always play devil's advocate.
Say,
wait,
that doesn't make sense because we're
not in a,
in a large way.
That's exactly what Watson does.
And the other good thing to do is get
yourself a watson and the sense of get
yourself someone you know with whom you
can discuss things,
someone who listens to you.
Um,
it's really good to talk things through.
And I think you often find that when you
see gaps in logic,
when you say something out loud,
that'd be store.
Um,
you never really voiced.
And so one of the ways it can do that
is,
is you think that you know what you're
doing.
Actually pretend that we need to explain
it to someone else and explain it out
loud or you can even write it out.
So writing is,
it was a good exercise.
Do what you can say he did.
I really understand this because writing
shows gaps in logic very,
very strongly.
So if I write something and I'm like,
wait,
that little bit of sense in my head,
but on the page,
it's settling.
Doesn't make sense.
I have to try to figure out why that's
the case and anyone to do that.
Um,
do you don't need anyone else.
You don't want to talk to yourself.
You don't need to imagine conversations,
all you have to do is write out your
argument as if you were explaining it to
someone else or write out their thinking
is a few words to someone else.
That's interesting.
Yeah.
That's why it can be helpful to keep it
a journal.
I know that I've experienced that in
writing a journal that you,
you start writing,
you know your thoughts about things and
you're surprised to like,
uh,
your perspective on them is completely
different from what you might have
thought it was in your head.
So,
um,
so I have a couple of questions of my
own.
Um,
and maybe in the interest of time I'll
ask just one of them and then see if it
has a follow up.
Um,
and uh,
and we'll,
we'll,
we'll close out.
I'm looking over here at another
computer.
That's why I'm not looking at everyone.
Um,
many of the points you multitasking.
Yes,
I am.
It's he media multitasking.
Um,
very well.
many of the points you make in the
workshop add up to the fact that we
can't trust our own common sense.
That,
and,
and in your book of course mastermind,
um,
our minds make up stories.
They're biased to pay attention to some
things and ignore others.
Uh,
and in order to solve problems more
effectively,
we need to examine our assumption
assumption's rigorously and consider the
data in ways that don't necessarily come
naturally to us.
Um,
which is very counterintuitive in some
ways to at least,
uh,
the culture I grew up in American
culture of,
you know,
trust yourself,
and trust with sort of your common sense
in a sense.
Um,
not only is this practically hard as
we're biased to trust ourselves,
it might also be emotionally hard in
that many of us construct our identities
and sense of self worth,
security,
et Cetera,
around self trust,
around trust in our own sort of common
sense.
What are your thoughts about how to
manage,
like if somebody is training themselves
to be more skeptical and more critical
of their own thinking,
how to manage that transition
emotionally and otherwise?
I think that's a really interesting
question and I think that the way,
the way that I view it is it's not,
don't trust yourself.
It's don't trust yourself when you have
no reason to do so when you have no
experience in something.
So experts can trust all of their
instincts and their common sense in
their areas of expertise.
And the problem comes when non-experts
have a book common sense opinion that
really is just coming out of nowhere.
And we do that all the time.
There are areas where we're expert,
um,
but then we do the exact same thing in
areas where we're not really experts.
So if you think for instance,
I see this person and he's acting
shifted to me,
my common sense as he's doing something
wrong,
oh you shouldn't distress that.
That common sense because you're an
expert in looking at people and in
reading body language,
you've done that your entire life.
So something as simple as that who
actually aren't an expert in you should
listen to yourself even if you're not
really sure why you think something
might be picking up on cues,
the triggers.
Ask Yourself,
why do I think this person's acting
suspicious?
Am I actually reading body language or
am I using non expertise?
Am I putting someone else in my putting
someone else in this situation and this
person just reminds me of someone I
don't like.
So now I think they're shifting.
So you have to,
it's not about not trusting yourself per
se.
It's about examining the reasons for
your assumptions and always saying,
okay,
am I actually making this judgment based
on some sort of expertise or am I like
one of those people who makes a decision
about whether or not I'm going to hire
someone in the first 30 seconds of an
interview just because I liked them or
didn't like them?
Um,
in which case there's no expertise
there.
You,
you don't know anything about the
person.
Um,
so I think it depends on the judgment
and it depends on what you're using to
get there,
if that makes sense.
It makes sense.
Okay.
So I think,
yeah,
I'll ask one more question and then
we'll,
and then we'll turn it over to said,
this is about,
uh,
the value of creativity and imagination.
How well two psychologists at this point
understand creativity.
I imagine it's not something,
it's not a subject that gets,
you know,
heavy research dollars thrown at it.
Um,
uh,
have their insights yet yielded anything
that you would think of as a sort of
practical,
useful approach to teaching or enhancing
people's creativity,
um,
beyond letting your mind do its thing,
you know,
daydreaming,
etc.
Yeah.
I think what we're starting to
understand creativity,
but it's a really,
really hard thing to study because there
are many different types of creativity.
There are many manifestations of
creativity.
It's not like an overarching entity.
You are or you are not creative.
You're creative in different ways.
And there are different ways of having
creative insights.
Um,
so psychologists are a little bit
limited in that they have to study
things in a laboratory and so they have
to have an artificial paradigm.
And so they try to figure out,
well,
okay,
how can I proximate creativity.
Um,
so that's why you get a lot of these
studies that look at the Eureka moment,
the Aha moment where you are able to
kind of put things together in a new
way.
That's one way that you can study
creativity.
But it's a V and we're learning a lot
about that.
We're aligning how people can become
better at that.
But once again,
that's a very,
very specific type of creative thinking
and being good at those kinds of Eureka
problems is not the same thing as being
more creative.
Um,
overall what we do know,
um,
that's something that everyone can do is
that for whatever reason,
being in nature helps people become
better at problem solving.
So being surrounded by trees,
by water,
um,
kind of those types of things for
whatever reason,
make people better able to,
um,
to have insights into think of
imaginative solutions.
So it's not just a Eureka moment,
it's also,
you know,
you'll become better eyebrow
brainstorming.
The quality of your brainstorm ideas
becomes deeper.
Um,
and the more that we actually,
the more we learned to pay attention,
the more we focus on things.
That's the other part of the puzzle.
There's is this,
this focus part of creativity.
People always say that it's,
um,
taking the breaks and those breaks are
incredibly important,
but you have to realize that for homes
and for any other creative person,
there's also a lot of hard work that
comes before and you can't distract
yourself while we're doing that.
So homes does have these bouts of
intense thinking,
young concentration where he's really
mulling over the problem before he takes
his break.
He takes his brake,
he already has a lot of that work to
through.
And whenever you hear of,
you know,
people like [inaudible] or anyone else
who is often used as an example of
breakthrough creativity and they spent
weeks,
hours,
you know,
years sometimes mulling over problems.
And so then the insight comes in a
second.
But there are different parts to that.
So I think we can train our
concentration,
we can take more walks in natural
habitats and those are the things we
definitely know can help.
Um,
it's a field that's,
that's getting more and more attention.
I think people would really love to know
how to become more creative.
And the good news is that you can be,
you can become more creative.
And I think that everyone has the
certain degree of creativity in them.
It's not the type of thing,
you know,
you can't say,
oh,
I'm not a creative person.
I don't think not creative people exist.
Hmm.
Great.
So listen up all you people who like me,
who think of yourselves as creative and
live in big cities,
time to get out into the park.
Um,
and one of the most interesting points I
think,
you know,
Maria that you make in your book,
um,
mastermind and,
and in the big thing,
mentor workshop,
how to think like Sherlock Holmes,
um,
is this fact that this is that true?
Like homes is a creative problem solver.
That he does take information and
recombine it in imaginative ways.
You know,
we tend to associate creativity falsely,
um,
with the arts.
Uh,
only often and,
and,
and think of science and,
you know,
being a detective as somehow more kind
of rational,
linear,
analytical,
not creative.
And I think that's a really,
really important point that you make.
Um,
okay.
So,
uh,
with that said,
um,
said,
did you have any follow up questions
you'd like to ask before we,
uh,
four we wind this up.
Uh,
oh,
I have a simple one and maybe it just
got to be good way close.
I'm kind of curious.
Uh,
Maria,
did you ever have,
or what was an Aha moment for you?
I've been reading any of the,
uh,
home stories.
What was the Aha moment
or was there a particular Aha moment for
you reading any of the stories where you
just,
you know,
we're just kind of hits you and you're
like,
oh,
that makes perfect sense.
And the way that he was approaching a
problem?
Well,
I definitely had an Aha moment when I
realized that I wanted to write about
homes and started really reading all the
stories and I was,
it was more of a reading all of them in
very close succession very,
very closely,
you know,
underlining,
highlighting,
writing notes in the margins,
kind of doing this very close reading.
Um,
and my Aha moment was that Sherlock
Holmes really is a different type of
thinker.
The thinker that I remembered from
childhood.
And I think that he's often portrayed as
being,
because he's so imaginative and creative
and warm and if not a cold machine at
all.
And it was very,
to me it was one of those,
Huh.
Why do people always think of him as
this logical Automaton,
uh,
as,
as a computer when he's anything,
but when all of the things that may
come,
Sherlock Holmes are things that a
computer can't accomplish.
And that to me was exactly,
exactly.
It was really eye opening because even
from my childhood,
from reading the stories,
I didn't remember that I instead had
that kind of stereotype of peace,
this computer,
just this perfectly logical person.
He's anything about it.
Yeah.
Okay,
great.
Um,
so I,
I want to thank everyone out there in
the live audience for joining us today.
Um,
and Sid Burgess from our big thing
mentor community and a special thanks to
Maria Konnikova for being with us.
Um,
you've,
you've been watching our big thing,
mentor hangout with Maria Konnikova,
author of mastermind,
how to think like Sherlock Holmes.
Um,
visit youtube.com/user/big think mentor
to take Maria's workshop on thinking
skills from the master detective and
learn life skills for personal and
professional growth.
I'm Jason Gods and editor with big think
and thanks everyone for joining us
today.
Sit and Maria,
thanks.
Thank you.
Thanks for having us.